hace 7 años me encontré con mi hijo
haciéndome una pregunta
yo me dijo papá
necesito una cuenta de gmail elige hijo
para para que la cuenta de gmail papá
necesito una cuenta de gmail no
preguntes después te explico llegó y me
dijo dije bueno vamos a crear la cuenta
de gmail a mi hijo
cogí mis en mi teléfono celular
le active dentro de lo que medio conocía
en ese momento del celular una cuenta de
gmail es un correo electrónico yo pienso
que no hay problema
eso era lo que yo conocía hasta el
momento
siete días después vuelvo a [ __ ]
nuevamente el teléfono celular y me doy
cuenta que mi hijo había cargado cinco
vídeos de youtube
y dije pero qué es esto me dio me dio
alegría y me dio susto al mismo tiempo
saber de que mi hijo de 5 años estaba
cargando vídeos a youtube y lo estaba
haciendo como si fuera un youtuber
porque él cogía se grababa grabado unos
compañeritos y hacía como si fuera una
especie de tutorial y yo dije yo no soy
capaz de hacer esto ni siquiera sé cómo
cargar un vídeo a youtube
entonces le dije nuevamente a mi hijo
hijo venga cómo se hace para cargar un
vídeo a youtube
mi hijo ay papá definitivamente mire
aquí hay un botoncito hay una pestaña
muy chiquita que tiene una flechita
hacia arriba usted le da clic ahí y de
una vez carga el vídeo era muy sencillo
cargar un vídeo de youtube y mi hijo me
enseñó cómo cargar un vídeo youtube hace
7 años eso me sirvió experiencia para
para poder hacer como reflexión y decir
no soy capaz de manejar herramientas
básicas que hoy en día los niños las
conocen y las dominan a la perfección
estoy en un cargo en ese momento estaba
recibiendo yo un cargo especial como
docente en la escuela de posgrados de
policía y digo tengo que aprender cómo
utilizar estas herramientas hice una
pequeña exploración inicie una
investigación sobre cuáles son esas
herramientas que podemos utilizar
nosotros dentro de los procesos
académicos hice un trabajo bien riguroso
de sondear dentro de internet primero
aprender a navegar en internet es bien
importante porque no sabía buscar cuando
me encontré algo de google lo único que
sabía era que era un buscador y fui
descubriendo todas las herramientas que
tiene google para poder trabajar
colaborativamente para ahorrar tiempo
para hacer trabajos en línea para
almacenar información en la nube no
sabía que era la nube ese concepto de la
nube era era nuevo también para mí como
que había escuchado por ahí hablar
algunas personas que saben un poquito
más de tecnología el tema de la nube
pero comencé a descubrir que la nube es
como un disco duro virtual que tenemos
ahí
puesto a través de una cuenta de gmail
una cuenta de google para almacenar
información lo importante de esto es que
estas herramientas que ofrecen muchas
ventajas dentro de cualquier proceso no
solamente académico pues nos dan la
posibilidad de ser más efectivos más
eficientes mejores profesionales cuando
aprovechamos el potencial de estas
herramientas dentro de un proyecto
especial y así lo hicimos iniciamos un
primer proyecto un avance significativo
dentro de lo que estábamos nosotros
desarrollando en la escuela de posgrados
de policía que era la formación de todos
los oficiales de la policía nacional y
programas especiales que tiene la
escuela abiertos al público
implementamos las herramientas
tecnológicas dentro de los programas
académicos y vimos cómo esto generó un
gran impacto positivo en beneficio de
todos los programas así que descubrimos
logramos compartir digamos esa
experiencia de haber hecho todas estas
innovaciones al inicio porque para
nosotros fue fue un tema nuevo aprender
ar aulas virtuales aprender a manejar
evaluaciones en línea aprender a crear
cuestionarios aprender a hacer streaming
cuando yo hice mi primer streaming fue
una cosa increíble que descubrí también
porque prácticamente lo aprendí de la de
la internet y toda esa gran experiencia
que teníamos nosotros hasta el momento
digamos documentada en la escuela pues
estaba interesante lo contamos todas las
personas que llegaron al centro
educativo en la escuela de posgrados de
policías se daban cuenta de ese
potencial nos felicitaban por toda esta
gran innovación que estábamos
desarrollando dentro de esto pues fuimos
avanzando un poco más logramos poner
estas herramientas a disposición de los
proyectos de innovación ya no lo
llamamos investigación que fue un
proceso digamos de transición haciéndolo
mucho más amigable más entendible para
las personas que llegaban a participar
de los programas académicos como estas
herramientas ayudaban a investigar más a
investigar mejor a documentar digamos
toda la investigación dentro de un
proyecto
y haciendo que esto fuera más visible
poderle contar a otras personas lo que
estábamos haciendo dentro de la
innovación fue algo que permitió digamos
las herramientas que hemos descubierto
hicimos otro trabajo importante que fue
capacitar a los estudiantes que pasaban
por el centro educativo a los profesores
los profesores descubrieron también
estas herramientas con nosotros las
apropiaron dentro de su trabajo como
docente en el aula y vieron las bondades
y los beneficios tanto así que un día un
profesor se me acercó y me dijo capitán
yo en ese momento era capitán gracias
por lo que me enseñó sobre google para
educación sobre el classroom tuve una
pequeña conferencia en un colegio donde
estoy enseñando y me contrataron ahorita
me va a ganar unos recursos extras por
la enseñanza que usted nos dio muchas
gracias yo profesor con todo gusto
estamos para servirles bien entonces
estas experiencias positivas
pues no se quedan aquí en la escuela voy
a conectar ahorita un poquito la
experiencia con algo que me pasó también
hace aproximadamente un año me encontré
una docente que me contó que había hecho
un negocio
dije profe cómo está cómo me eleva bien
mayor acabo de hacer un negocio de 300
millones de pesos fabuloso fantástico y
de qué se trata hijo compre un colegio
bien profesor interesante la educación y
cómo funciona dónde está el colegio dijo
pues el colegio queda en ciudad bolívar
allá en ciudad bolívar tengo más o menos
80 niños matriculados en este momento y
tengo 5 profesores que dan el último
barrio de ciudad bolívar que se llama
buenos aires yo chevere profe
interesante la felicito ojalá algún día
yo pueda trabajar en algún colegio le
dije dijo sí pero pues por ahora tengo
algunos inconvenientes porque no me
alcanzan los recursos para pagar la
planta docente a veces tengo que sacar
de mi bolsillo de lo que gano en otras
instituciones para pagar el sueldo de
los profesores
yo he bueno entonces el negocio como que
no está tan bueno porque si está
invirtiendo de su bolsillo pues está
perdiendo mi hijo no mire qué bueno no
sé cómo lo quieran ver pero yo estoy
ganando algo especial me dijo la
profesora cuando
el colegio los niños se acercan y me
abrazan y me dan las gracias y casi no
me dejan entrar al colegio esa felicidad
tan grande que esos niños sienten cuando
me ven mi radio a mí también y yo creo
que son la mejor paga que tengo en este
momento dije pues usted tiene un corazón
grande profesora porque está invirtiendo
bastante de su sueldo para esos niños
que lo necesitan mi hijo si
definitivamente son niños que requieren
el apoyo la educación es la única manera
de transformar sociedades y yo lo hago
desinteresadamente no importa que en
este momento no esté ganando muchos
recursos pero tal vez lo voy a hacer mi
hijo tengo una estrategia también estoy
lanzando por los grupos de amigos de
whatsapp la convocatoria para que
apadrinen niños el apadrinar niños es
simplemente aportar con 50 mil pesos al
mes el derecho a la pensión del niño y
ya con eso yo me defiendo allá en mi
colegio me dijo la profesora y yo dije
profe pues interesante cuente conmigo
voy a ver cómo la puedo ayudar
casi tres días después que tuvimos esa
conferencia un evento especial acá en la
escuela donde trabajo y casualmente que
se rifaban unos artículos
ese día yo entré como con la conciencia
de que de que ese día era importante
para mí que alguna de esas cosas que
están rifando ahí me las iba a ganar y
algo que me propuse es si yo me gano
algo dentro de este evento es eso que yo
me gane se lo voy a entregar a esos
niños que necesitan allá el apoyo y como
como si alguien me estuviera escuchando
así fue
antes de finalizar como el último premio
que era los premios ya más importantes y
los principales me llaman con el número
que yo tenía y me ha ganado una
bicicleta
yo dije como que estoy yo ya lo yo ya lo
tenía estos donde ya vi tal vez pero así
fue lo que pensé llamé a la profesora a
las dos horas llegó y una vez por acá
pasó y le dije profesora llévese esta
bicicleta hay una persona que está en
250 mil pesos si quiere la venta de una
vez o si no llegue se la mire así usted
de pronto tras la falla en el colegio le
saca más recursos
por favor al niño que usted quiera que
usted considere esos 150 mil pesos o
para que usted lo que necesita ya la
profesora súper contenta se llevó la
bicicleta después me llamó nuevamente
arme las gracias me envió una foto de
una niña muy linda que era la que había
recibido el premio yo me sentí bendecido
también por ayudar a esa profesora sin
embargo después estaba yo en mi oficina
reflexionando sobre todas estas cosas y
me di cuenta pues que que podía hacer
algo más aparte de tener nosotros la
experiencia de trabajar acá con las
herramientas de internet y toda la
tecnología pues dije por qué no le
ayudamos también a esta profesora que
necesita ya en su colegio de pronto un
docente de informática de pronto que le
ayuden en otros elementos que ella
requiera para mejorar la parte de la
tecnología en el colegio entonces la
llamé y le dije profe por qué no por qué
no implementamos las herramientas
tecnológicas en su colegio y ella me
dijo plano o claro que sí mayor
y logramos que la plataforma de google
para educación que es una licencia
gratis para las instituciones educativas
se implementará dentro del colegio de la
institución educativa buenos aires así
fue cómo llegamos nosotros a impactar
dentro de la institución educativa
también con algo que que está a
disposición digamos de las instituciones
pero a veces no lo conocen que son las
herramientas de google para educación
también le dije a la profesora cuando
cuando llegamos la primera vez al
colegio lleguemos con un sentido aparte
de enseñar las herramientas
desarrollamos nosotros una metodología
para que los niños puedan investigar
puedan aprender puedan ellos presentar
toda la información que tiene y sobre
todo se vuelvan autodidactas la mejor
manera de utilizar el internet buscar
buena información en internet porque hay
cosas malas pero si yo soy autodidacta
si yo puedo utilizar el internet como
una herramienta positiva para suplir
esas necesidades de información que a
veces no las entregan las instituciones
educativas pues estoy haciendo algo
positivo entonces así fue enseñamos a
los niños el uso de algunas herramientas
que son básicas para que investiguen
para que ellos puedan aprender cómo ser
mejores personas también dentro de ese
entorno a pesar de las dificultades y a
pesar de los problemas que ellos tengan
pues pueden utilizar esto como una buena
herramienta enseñarle a sus padres
lograr que de alguna manera el poco
acceso que tienen a la tecnología lo
utilicen de la mejor manera y así fue
como nosotros
digamos expandir un poco esa experiencia
positiva exitosa que teníamos dentro de
nuestra escuela dentro de un colegio
ciudad bolívar ha ayudado también por
otras personas logramos digamos
entregarles a ellos unos enlaces
especiales hay una página que se llama
internet para educar y esta página
también ayuda y contribuye a las
personas que quieran aprender de manera
positiva de estas herramientas hay unas
personas que nos ayudan dentro de este
propósito especial detrás de internet
para educar hay una persona que se llama
william vélez que nos ha ayudado
muchísimo y otras personas amigos
españoles que también contribuyen con
este propósito y están atentos cada vez
que yo los llamo a ver qué proyecto
nuevo hay en que pueden ayudar en que
pueden colaborar esta es simplemente una
una pequeña experiencia que queríamos
compartir pues haciendo saber de que con
con poquitas acciones que estamos
nosotros desarrollando porque pudiéramos
hacer más préstamos llegando a impactar
una comunidad vulnerable que que
requiere y de esta manera construir una
mejor sociedad gracias